In 1964, a woman named Kitty Genovese was raped and stabbed to death in the middle of an open
apartment complex in Queens, New York. It is said by New York Times, that about 37
bystanders who witnessed the murder did not call for the police, nor did they help her in any
way.
Another similar incident happened when a 2 year old named Wang Yue was wondering around
an open market when she was  run over by a truck. The truck did stop, but only for a moment,
running her over with the front and back tires. Nineteen people walked past her body, some
stopping to stare, but none to help. It was only an hour later that a bystander helped Wang Yue,
but unfortunately, it was too late. She died in the hospital shortly after.
Why is it that no one helped Kitty or Wang when they were in clear need of aid? Well, a possible
explanation could be because of the 'bystander effect' or 'bystander apathy.' It's when individuals
are less likely to take action when others are present due to the diffusion of responsibility in
social influences. In other words, the greater amount of bystanders, the less likely it is for an
individual to take action. People in the group assume that someone else will help and that their
individual action is not needed. But, if everybody in the group all has this apathetic manner,
incidents like Kitty Genovese's murder and Wang Yue's hit and run will happen.
How could this behavior be explained? Well, according to Richard Dawkins, a professor at
Oxford University, what differentiates humans from every other species in the animal kingdom,
is the development of the prefrontal cortex, or PFC. The medial and dors-medial parts of the PFC
controls cognitive function and rational thought. The argument is that the empathy and ability to
mentalize can motivate nonselfish behavior. Humans are special because we can choose to act
kindly to our fellow humans. However, evolutionary biology says that humans, throughout
history, have only acted out prosocial behaviors to benefit themselves. Or else, nobody would
have survived. Which puts the saying "Survival of the fittest" on the play.
An infamous example of apathy is the Holocaust, in which the world closed its eyes during this
catastrophe. People could have spoken out to help individuals who were afraid of speaking if
they could have suffered the same fate as the people they were trying to help. So, biologically
and socially, humans are just inclined to be apathetic and ignore things in which they don't
benefit from or which they could be harmed by.
Since we're the only species to have PFC, I don't want to get involved is often said whenever an
undesirable event should occur. Bystanders will report not wanting to be involved because they
fear negative consequences for themselves. And also, because they assume someone else could
offer help, not just me. But, if people were more aware, events like Wang Yue and Kitty where people
didn't respond, could have been avoided.
So, just remember, even if you're just helping a sick family member or friend, maybe even
helping someone carry something heavy, don't even nudge them off because you think someone else
could help them. Lend a hand. It could mean the world to somebody.
What are your opinions on the bystander effect? Do you disagree or agree on it, or have some
different kind of thoughts? Well, make sure to subscribe to Psych2Go's channel and visit their
Facebook, Twitter and Tumblr. Thank you for watching and have a wonderful day.